Pakistan is holding the global Health
security Summit here in Islamabad which
is also attended by ministers from
several countries and delegations from
Saudi Arabia Qatar the United States the
United Nations non-governmental
organizations are all present here the
Endeavor is basically to come out with a
United response on a global level to
deal with pandemics and contagious
diseases around the world and to hammer
out some sort of a plan in order to
alleviate uh the countries that are less
privileged lwi income countries to be
able to raise Finance for them we've
been speaking to the minister to tell us
about the importance of this Summit
Pakistan has taken the first step
towards making H Global Health security
a key pivotal agenda in the
international health and development
agenda there was an amazing Gathering of
70 different nationalities colors
ethnicities religions and skill from
different countries there was one
resolution and the resolution is towards
Unity solidarity and Harmony amongst the
nation states
Partners un bodies and implementers for
a secure and safer world the minister of
course also highlighting the issues of
the pales Ians where a health emergency
is already happening on the ground
making Health apolitical is very
important when we see in the context of
the Gaza Massacre
happen we w't
immediate to the massacre of humanity we
want a stoppage of killing health
workers ambul targeting ambulances
buming Health
Facilities we want an excess for each
and every individual that is in need of
healthcare services in Gaza this is an
apolitical Venture that transcends
Beyond religious boundaries ethnic and
National boundaries and it is an
important step to try to come out with a
concerted policy in order to deal with
national and international emergencies
when it comes to contagious diseases as
well as pandemics Kamal Hyer Al jaaz
Islamabad make sure to subscribe to our
Channel to get the latest news from Al
jaer